Hi.
I'm Grzegorz, and I'm
the CEO at NapoleonCat,
which is a social media
marketing dashboard.
I would like to
give you a few tips
on how to measure
the effectiveness
of your social media channels,
and social media marketing
activities, and how you can try
to make more sense out of it.
Of course, social media
presence is a must
for all the companies,
especially all sorts
of online businesses.
But oftentimes, people
wonder whether it's worth
investing more in this
platform, or that platform,
or whether my activities
actually bring any benefit
to our business.
The way we approach it is that
we try to tag and measure every
piece of content that we publish
on our social media platforms
like Facebook fan page, or a
Google+ profile, or LinkedIn,
or a Twitter profile.
And we track the
effectiveness of this content
of different
platforms by measuring
how this converts into
registrations in our service
and in actual sales.
The way we do it we basically
use the Google's UTM tagging,
and we tag each
link that we publish
on those different
social media platforms
so that later, we can see
where the traffic comes from
and how it converts into
registrations and sales.
And thanks to that,
we can not only
say that this platform
brings us higher traffic,
but we can also identify those
platforms and those pieces
of content that convert best
to actual sales, which are
subscriptions to our product.
It actually works
so well that we
have decided to implement
this feature in our product.
When building your social
media marketing tactics,
you don't have to rely only on
your experience and your data.
You can also try to look at your
competitors or the benchmarks
that you think are
best for your business.
And based on the
information collected
from their activities, you
can optimize your social media
tactics.
For example, you can monitor
using different tools.
You can monitor
the effectiveness
and the engagement
with the content
they publish on the different
social media platform,
and track the most
effective pieces of content,
the ones that get the highest
engagement-- what type
of for content this is,
for example, whether this
is video, or pictures, or
links to external websites.
You can also measure
which days of the weeks
are most effective for building
an engagement with the content,
even what parts of the day are
most effective for publishing
content.
And based on that
information gathered
from many competitive
profiles, you
can build and adjust your
social media tactics,
in order to build the
most effective tactics
for your own brand.